[Music]
eye-popping thick rimmed and instantly
recognizable bubbles glasses in the hit
cult TV show trailer park boys are as
tied to his character as much as his
love for cats but how did bubbles
acquire his signature look Trailer Park
Boys started as a Grassroots project
that slowly grew into a cult classic and
despite its popularity it still checks
many of the requisite boxes for cult
status after the show became a hit on
Netflix Trailer Park Boys garnered a
loyal fan base that fell in love with
the likes of Julian Ricky Bubbles and Mr
Leahy Trailer Park Boys May basically be
kind of sort of mainstream now but no
matter how many episodes the fans
consume die hards and first timers alike
may find themselves wondering one
particular question what's up with
bubbles glasses there's no doubt that
the well-meaning bubbles who is played
by Mike Smith is a massive breakout
character and those extra thick Coke
bottle specks of his are are almost too
good to be true so where did the eyewear
come from did the makers of the show run
against their Lo-Fi production values
and commission the glasses or did they
luck out by finding the glasses that
let's face it look more or less like
bubbles found them dirt cheap at a yard
sale somewhere as luck would have it the
latter option actually isn't too far
from the iconic glasses true origin
story here's how the makers of trailer
park boys came up with bubbles glasses
Mike clattenberg the creator of Trailer
Park Boys told sharp magazine that he
hired Mike Smith to do sound for the
feature film that gave birth to the
series which was shot in 1998 at his
house Smith put on the infamous glasses
and eased effortlessly into character
clattenberg liked what he saw and as
they say a star was born Jean-Paul
Tremblay who plays Julian the
muscle-bound trailer park resident who
wears black shirts and always has a
glass of rum and coke in hand is also
enthused about the way Smith introduced
bubbles to them he said my Mike Smith
totally developed that character he
threw those glasses on one day and we
were like wow this guy needs to be on
the show I don't know how you passed
your eye test son but you can't see Jack
in the very same interview Smith himself
explained how he came to possess those
sweet brains Smith explained my
girlfriend at the time was in Texas
visiting family and they went to an
estate sale and she found these glasses
they were 50 cents and she knew that I
would think they were funny because they
were so thick so she bought them as a
joke showcase wasn't as convinced about
Bubbles as the makers at the show were
at first but clattenberg eventually
managed to persuade the channel to
include the character in the show though
he had to make a short film starring an
early version of bubbles to do so in
hindsight this was probably worth it as
clattenberg feels that trailer park boys
might not have succeeded at all without
the inclusion of bubbles while the
glasses are no doubt an instrumental
part of what just might be the single
most important character in trailer park
boys Smith had to suffer for his art
because bubble's signature eyewear is
just about as comfortable to use as
you'd expect however he eventually
learned to deal with it Smith told big
issue in 2013 they give you a proper
whopping headache but now when I put
them on my brain turns off my eye pain
somehow
[Music]